we're joined now by the chair of the ERG
group of conservative MPS Mark Francois
um firstly you should say you've got a
very important role in this with the
chair of the group that you represent
you're a skeptic conservatives now we
haven't seen the deal no you haven't
seen the deal no we've got a few leaked
details what would you make of what
would you know so far well just quickly
the context this is all about upholding
The Good Friday agreement that's what
everyone is trying to achieve that's
been the Bedrock of Peace in Northern
Ireland for a quarter of a century and
the Prime Minister writing in the Sunday
Times this morning said quite rightly
that the protocol has now unbalanced The
Good Friday agreement the late Lord
Trimble a noble Laureate he's the man
that helped create the Good Friday
agreement with John Hume said in May
2022 a few months before he sadly died
that he and John human made great
sacrifices to bring peace to Northern
Ireland and that was now all at risk so
this has to be solved so that we can
uphold The Good Friday agreement that is
the that's the imperative
and in order to do that we have to get a
deal that both nationalists and
unionists feel comfortable with because
the fundamental underlying principle
that runs throughout the Good Friday
agreement like a golden thread is the
principle of consent so that feels
important
the main unionist party are you
effectively saying that if they don't
support the deal you're not going to
support it either well the government is
saying that the foreign secretary said
on Friday that the government would not
sign off on any protocol deal without
the dups backing so that's James
cleverly saying that and I think that's
just a practical reality
because if the dup don't consent to the
deal then it's simply not going to fly
and and that's been absolutely obvious
right from the word go now the dupr
friends and allies of ourselves and the
European research group we admire them
why
when a lot of these people went into
politics you know some decades ago they
did that knowing that their lives might
be under threat from the provisional Ira
one of the most ruthless terrorist
organizations in the world I mean so
none of your viewers I'm sure had to
look under their car before they went to
work in the week but the people in the
dup had to do that every day for many
years but they went to work anyway so
the point is these people won't be
bullied by anybody they will make their
own decision on whether or not or not
it's right to agree to the deal and to
re-enter storms we know don't we what
they're gonna say because
they said it a pmqs they said that we're
not going to back a deal if the European
courts of Justice have any oversight
over it which we know effectively that
they will and also that the text itself
has to be Rewritten that's also not
going to happen so the DP aren't going
to well the dup are more than capable of
speaking for themselves they are not
shrinking violence but we can read
between the lines of what they're saying
well to me it doesn't feel like they're
going to back the deal they have been
frighteningly consistent including to us
that they their bottom line is they
absolutely cannot accept a deal that
means EU law is still Superior to UK law
in Northern Ireland if there's no EU law
in Northern Ireland that there's nothing
for the European court of justice to
adjudicate upon now we don't know what
is in this deal we haven't seen the
legal text why does that matter because
if you're talking about altering
protocols or treaties that always comes
down to a definite of legal text they've
made very plain that they would not sign
up to anything until they've read the
legal text I mean we are we're in the
same position what MP worth their
assault would vote for something without
having read it so unless that legal text
when we see it
expunges EU law from Northern Ireland I
think it's very unlikely that the dup
was supported in which case the whole
process won't work I want to talk a bit
more about how you believe you've been
treated or let into the process in a
moment but just talking about that EU
law we heard from Dominic Raab he said
look if we make the trade easier then
that will mean that there will be less
of a role for the no less of a role is
not enough so that's not enough no no
just just putting a couple of you know
intermediate phases in
in a situation where you still end up
with the European court of justice is
effectively sophistry I mean we're not
stupid
what we want is a situation where EU law
is expunged from Northern Ireland so it
is treated on the same basis as England
Scotland and Wales so any role for the
ecj at all
you're not back here well it does we've
left the European Union it doesn't have
that role now in England or in Scotland
or in Wales so if we're going to treat
Northern Ireland as an integral part of
the United Kingdom then we have to get
rid of EU law in Northern Ireland we've
been absolutely consistent on this so In
fairness to them have the dup and
sometimes we feel like how many more
times do we have to tell the government
but I think what's really interesting is
the foreign secretaries
certainly twig this and that's why he
said that the government wouldn't sign
up to anything that didn't have the dups
backing that to me is just an acceptance
of practical political reality when were
you first
asked your opinion when was the ERG
first consulted about this well we've
had meetings with you know with the
government ongoing for for a number of
months on this but what we still haven't
seen is a legal text and I'm sorry to
press the matter but as I hope I've
managed to explain you know when you're
talking about protocols and treaties the
wording matters now interestingly when
you look at the wording of the Good
Friday agreement and this is a point
that a lot of people don't appreciate
sorry the wording of the protocol
actually it hasn't is a clause called
Clause 13 8. and what that says is
any subsequent agreement between the
union and the United Kingdom shall
indicate the parts of this protocol
which it supersedes which it goes on to
say can be done in a whole or in part so
the protocol contained within it the
seeds for it to be replaced it was
always meant to be a temporary
Arrangement whereas the Good Friday
agreement was meant to be permanent so
with it using 13 8 you can amend or even
get rid of the protocol if you can come
up with a better way of doing this and
for two years we consistently advocated
a different system which is known as
Mutual enforcement
do you feel like there's been a bit of
political naivety from the government on
this now you haven't seen the legal text
they haven't brought the dep on the side
the reports in the papers this morning
that there was a bit of a disagreement
should we say between Rishi sunak and
the dep when they went to Northern
Ireland do you think they've gone away
you know they've done the homework
they've answered the essay question the
way that they think they've wanted to
but they haven't done the political well
I think it was someone in the dup who a
couple of days ago said that this is or
in terms this is a very odd way of going
about it we're the people they
ultimately need to convince and they
haven't even shown us the text so at
some point they're going to have to fess
up this text and then members of
parliament are going to want to you know
go through it in fine detail and decide
whether or not to support it I'm in the
unusual position this morning of
agreeing with David Lammy in that he
just said on your program a few minutes
ago Parliament should not be rushed I
mean if I were advising the Prime
Minister my honest advice to him would
be don't try and bounce Parliament next
week because that is likely to go badly
wrong if you look at all the history of
this which is complex
trying to bounce Parliament usually ends
badly so if they do want if they've got
a deal they're proud of show us the text
let us run it by our lawyers let us
fully understand what it means and then
at that point we might be ready to vote
on it but it would be a very bad idea
you say that you're talking about a boat
there yeah there might not even be a
vote well if you look if you're going to
make any meaningful changes to the
protocol
you're going to have to have a bill so
that's going to mean at some point
you're going to have to have a vote I
think given all the history of this for
the government to try and bludgeon this
through the House of Commons without a
vote of any kind would be incredibly
unwise and I say that as someone who was
years ago a senior with myself
position is already pretty precarious
right the polls the
pulling for the conservatives you've got
to divide a party
if this goes wrong for a Richie soon
actually can't get it through do you
think that's the beginning of the end
look we want the prime minister to
succeed we want him to come up with a
deal that everybody can support
so but in order to do that it's going to
have to be a deal that gets rid of you
look let me try and put it like this
ultimately this isn't about red Lanes or
green Lanes or cycle Lanes it's about
who governs it's about whose law is
Sovereign in Northern Ireland legally
whose writ runs
and we need in order to solve this
problem and to uphold The Good Friday
agreement and the stop is going
backwards in Northern Ireland which
absolutely nobody wants to see we need
to get rid of EU law in Northern Ireland
and that's what our negotiators have got
to press for and if they can't get it
then we need to use the northern line
and protocol bill which is currently
stalled in the Lords in order to achieve
that aim we've got the protocol Bill
there ready to go it it flew through the
commons it's stuck in the Lords and if
the Lords we should reintroduce it and
if the Lord's trying to gut the bill we
should Parliament act it okay thank you
very much for being on the program this
morning thank you for having me on